قد يكون للطائرة التالية التي تسافر على
متنها أجنحة عملاقة يمكن طيها حتى في
نهاياتها ، وقد أنهت بوينج تصميمًا أساسيًا
لطائرة 777 9x التي يقول صانع الطائرات
إنها ستكون أكبر طائرة ذات محركين
في العالم المتحمس للطيران
والمسافرين الجويين المخضرمين.
حول طائرة Isle المزدوجة التي
تعمل منذ عامين ، تتطور
من طائرة 777 من الطراز القديم إلى طائرة ذات قوة طيران أكبر ،
وسيمنح سطح الجناح الإضافي
الطائرة مزيدًا من الرفع مثل طائرة شراعية
موفرة للوقود وتكاليف
تشغيل منخفضة الأجنحة ضخمة  يبلغ عرض كل واحدة مائة
وثمانية أقدام أي 33 مترًا ، وهي
كبيرة جدًا لدرجة أن شركة بوينج تضع مفصلات على
الطائرات بطول 12 قدمًا وطول أربعة أمتار ،
وتنطوي الأجنحة عندما تكون
الطائرات على الأرض حتى يتمكن الطيارون من الوصول
إلى البوابة دون الاصطدام  في
أي شيء ، يعد الطراز 777 9x أيضًا
بنوافذ أكبر ومقصورة أوسع من الطرز المنافسة ،
حيث سيكون قادرًا على نقل حوالي 400
راكب على طرق تمتد لمسافة 8700 ميلًا
، كل ذلك جزء من اتجاه
صناعي  أصبحت
بطانات الطائرات النفاثة طويلة المدى ذات المحركين الفائقة الكفاءة مثل الحافلات الهوائية
350 وبوينغ 787 دريملاينر
الجديدة فائقة الكفاءة ذات الممر الواحد
مثل بوينج 737
ماكس وطائرة إيرباص A330 نيو تبحث عن
777 9x لبدء طيران الركاب في
أقرب وقت  2020 توم باترسون سي إن إن